vous avez de la chance d'être avec nous
si vous avez des enfants des petits
enfants on a toujours des bons plans
avec notre nos maisons qui est là pour
me faire découvrir quelques livres
saints pas aujourd'hui on s'intéresse
aux super héros mais pas les super héros
comme on pourrait croire hein c'est pas
superman c'est pas batman c'est des
enfants qui ont des super pouvoirs s'est
satisfait oui alors on pourrait croire
qu'on est chanceux quand on est avec des
supers pouvoirs mais vous allez voir le
premier héros dont je vais vous parler
animal jack une vie qui est pas toujours
facile
son meilleur ami ne veut plus lui parler
c'est par an le sermonne en permanence
parce que son super pouvoir c'est de
pouvoir se transformer en animal alors
soit selon sa volonté
soit selon ses émotions c'est pas
évident tout le temps à gérer alors le
premier tome s'appelle le coeur de la
forêt écrit par miss rickli est illustré
par qui tout cela vous voyez c'est assez
sympa c'est édité par dupuis donc c'est
une bande dessinée
vous n'allez pas être supérieure et
comme tout super héros et bien il se
sent des obligations évidemment et le
jour où ses amis disparaissent les uns
après les autres
elle se dit il faut que je les retrouve
alors vous voyez c'est vraiment assez
sympa c'est mené tambour battant puisque
d'une seconde sur l'autre animal jack
qui peut se transformer en oiseau en
insectes en ours et c'est une surprise à
chaque page on m'a dit ah ouais c'est le
petit blond et c'est un émerveillement
parce que quand on électeurs on se dit
mais qu'est ce qui nous attend voilà en
quoi va-t-il se transformer et est-ce
que ça va lui servir ou lui porter
préjudice
c'est vraiment un livre très sympa si
vous aimez le tome 2 sortira fin août et
donc c'est vraiment le livre à mettre
dans les valises pour les enfants à
partir de 7 ans balade de 7 ans bon on
n'a rien pour léo n'est pour l'instant
pour votre viseur alors si ça peut se
raconter aussi parce que je sais pas
graphismes les enfants même plus jeunes
peuvent bien accroché bon ça s'appelle
anima jack canal ciac les éditions
dupuis
notre sélection avec un autre gamin
extraordinaire oui elle est ce sont
trois enfants qui s'appelle claire aaron
et norbert et olives en norvège alors je
vous emmène un petit peu loin avec ses
livres la c2a comme andreas et ovine
torcé terre vous me pardonnerez l'accent
ces publié à la joie de lire et ces
enfants là en fait ils n'ont pas
vraiment
voir il mais il aime jouer au super
héros ils ont la cape le costume et les
ont même le des noms de code et un jour
clair en fait elle apprend qu'un
industriel va installer un poulailler
industriel en fait à l'endroit de leur
cabane d'accord alors il décide de se
changer en super-héros évidemment et de
se mobiliser pour éviter ça et en fait
du coup avec ce livre est bien on
apprend qu'on peut devenir un super
héros
même en étant un enfant eh bien on se
mobilise en fait un super héros citoyens
si on veut donc c'est un livre vraiment
sympa moi j'ai trouvé ça sympa parce que
c'est un peu dans la veine du club des
cinq si vous voulez et puis ça parle
d'amitié d'amour de famille mais aussi
d'écologie de politique donc c'est je
pense que c'est à offrir aux enfants de
9 ans à peu près pour leur montrer que
ben est super héros c'est aussi être
citoyen ben oui qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir des super pouvoirs
voilà contacté le maire mobiliser les
habitants ont mené l enquête finalement
c'est aussi être un super héros et quand
on est un enfant dont on peut aussi
voilà s'emparer d'un sujet puisse
engager
ben c'est bien en tout cas ça y est en
levant ce moment ça s'adresse à des
enfants à partir de quel âge 9 ans à peu
près vous commencez à être bons lecteurs
mais comme s'illustrait je pense que ça
peut plaire l'amitié la famille l'amour
tout y est quoi la vraie trilogie comme
on les aime très bien norman n'a pas de
superpouvoirs paraît-il c'est vrai mais
je vous laisserai la découvrir il faut
lire le livre jusqu'à la fin ouais c'est
un livre de camélat benaouda c'est
publié chez gallimard jeunesse
et alors c'est un super ouvrage il faut
quand même savoir lire un petit peu plus
sensée à partir de 2 10 ans on va dire
et figurez vous que dans ce monde là
c'est l'inversé d'habitude tout le monde
a des super pouvoirs à l ac depuis qu'un
virus bleus c'est répondu sur la planète
c'est alors c'est des super-pouvoirs un
peu de toutes sortes 1 il ya commandé
l'eau voire la nuit enfin vraiment il ya
de tout et lui il est persuadé qu'il
n'en a pas un arrêt du coup ça devient
la catastrophe
ah oui et donc je vous laisserai lire le
livre et les jeunes aussi
et pour découvrir bien comment ça va se
passer norman n'a pas de superpouvoirs
un tout dernier en 10 secondes parce que
vous avez le super pouvoir de le faire
quelque chose de très très loin à la c1
c'est quoi exceptionnel ça s'appelle les
ces gestes de la famille papillon de
florentine qu'elle sait publié chez
casterman
et alors l'idée c'est que il y à des
familles qui ont des pouvoirs en fait
familiaux alors le pouvoir notamment
pour la famille papillon de faire le
bien
malgré soi en fait sans le faire exprès
les faisait gestes de la famille à
l'appeler y ont illustré juste part des
photos exceptionnelles jeu superbe
mercier merci non parce qu'on ne
rappelle pas parce qu'il ya le
feuilleton haletant les conseils de
lecture jeunesse il a retrouvé aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux